the u.s is reopening its consulate in
the occupied east jerusalem for
palestinians
the previous trump administration had
closed it in 2019
in an attempt to downgrade ties u.s
secretary of state anthony blinken made
the announcement after meeting
palestinian authority president mahmoud
ambass
he also pledged 32 million dollars for
the u.n agency supporting palestinian
refugees
more than 5 million as immediate aid for
gaza
the united states will be moving forward
with the process to reopen
our consulate uh in jerusalem that's an
important way for uh
for our country to engage with and
provide support
uh to the the palestinian people
we're also working in partnership with
the united nations
the international community the
palestinian authority the palestinian
people the government of israel
to assist in the relief and recovery
efforts in gaza
i want to thank the american
administration for the support given to
the state of palestine
the support has been given to us and we
appreciate it very much
we hope that the future will be full of
diplomatic activities in order to reach
a comprehensive solution
and to put an end to recent events
well earlier in the day he met israel's
caretaker prime minister benjamin
netanyahu and reaffirmed u.s
support while he didn't mention a
two-state solution for the palestinians
after both meetings he did say the two
sides deserve to live in
safety and dignity lincoln's visit is
seen as america's latest diplomatic
effort to strengthen a fragile ceasefire
between its ally israel
and hamas in gaza after an 11 day
conflict
assistance and investment like these
will help foster
a more stable environment that benefits
palestinians and also benefits
israelis prime minister and i had a
chance to discuss
other steps uh that need to be taken by
by leaders on on both sides to set a
better course
for their shared future as president
biden has said
we believe that palestinians and
israelis equally deserve to live
safely and securely to enjoy equal
measures of freedom opportunity
and democracy to be treated with dignity
and in that press conference netanyahu
warned israel will have a powerful
response if hamas
breaks the ceasefire we discussed
also how to improve
the lives and the conditions of the
palestinians the humanitarian conditions
in gaza
including the question of the return of
our
mias and two civilians who are there as
for peace itself with the palestinians a
formal piece i think president biden was
absolutely correct when he said
you're not going to get peace until
israel is recognized as an independent
jewish state
and that is the key i couldn't agree
more
our diplomatic editor james base is
following anthony blinken's trip he
joins us now
live from ramallah so james we heard
that uh speech a short while ago
or that address along with the
palestinian president what does it all
boil down to what sort of
biden middle east policies emerging here
well certainly the palestinian authority
now have someone to deal with
they're they're talking again to the
united states and this is the first
high-level meeting with the secretary of
state for
well over three years so for them that's
good news
but then look at what has actually been
achieved during this visit well
uh there is the promise maybe of help in
the future with reconstruction of gaza
there's a package of aid of 260 million
dollars which in
global scheme of things is not a large
amount of money and much of that
has already been announced there is the
decision to reopen
the u.s consulate general in jerusalem
let me just explain that
there is a there was a u.s embassy in
tel aviv that dealt with israel and the
u.s consulate general in east jerusalem
that dealt with the palestinians
president trump merged the two
and also moved the u.s embassy to
jerusalem now
they are going to have a consulate
general again a diplomatic
um representation to deal directly with
the palestinians so that
is a positive i think for the
palestinians but i think
where you really need to look and i'm
sure where palestinian thought is going
right now
is what the secretary blinking did not
say
uh during his meetings both with the
israelis and the palestinians
no mention of a two-state solution
no mention of ongoing peace negotiations
so
it seems the biden strategy the biden
policy
is to put a lid on this conflict and not
even try to make the effort
to try and solve it that i think is
because they believe right now
the time is not right for uh for for
peace
all right thanks so much james bay's
there let's cross over now to
ibrahim she's also joining us from
ramallah in the west bank and sony that
we look at the situation now and this
visit
the statements by anthony blink and is
it giving palestinians
much reason to have hope
well unlike the expectations in the
presidential headquarters here
that there might be a revival in the
peace process people here in the street
don't really pay attention to these
visits uh let alone have
hope from them they would tell you that
they've lost hope that the international
community is helping them in their cause
and i've been seeing throughout the past
few days speaking to people here in
ramallah
a more belief that israel only
understands the language of force this
is one statement that one
young man told me here he says that the
resistance factions in the besieged gaza
understand that language and know how to
uh pressure israel
these were his words so there is a
growing belief here among palestinians
is that there needs to be more uh to be
done when it comes to combating israel
rather than just the diplomatic approach
in march there was a
poll here done by a think tank in
ramallah and it showed that 37
of palestinians say that there should be
an armed struggle when it comes to
the issue with with israel while 36
percent
talked about negotiations and this was
before the recent escalation in gaza
so it could the numbers could even be
much different
in favor of an armed struggle so there's
also a growing dissatisfaction with the
palestinian authority
this palestinian society is young and
those youth have
almost been born after the ghost law
accords in the 90s and all of them heard
from their leaders are talks about peace
genuine peace
all these nice words but they've been
promised of a state
but all they see on the ground is that
the lands on which this state should
have been
built is shrinking further and further
and so that's why many here would tell
you that they're not looking for
managing
the conflict they're looking for a
better life
they're mainly looking for at the end of
the israeli occupation on their lands
all right we'll leave it there thanks so
much nida ibrahim